this episode is brought to you by eight
sleep my god am i in love with eight
sleep good sleep is the ultimate game
changer more than 30 percent of
americans struggle with sleep and i'm a
member of that sad group temperature is
one of the main causes of poor sleep and
heat has always been my nemesis i've
suffered for decades tossing and turning
throwing blankets off putting them back
on and repeating ad nauseam but now
i am falling asleep in record time
faster than ever why because i'm using a
simple device called the pod pro cover
by eight sleep it's the easiest and
fastest way to sleep at the perfect
temperature it pairs dynamic cooling and
heating with biometric tracking to offer
the most advanced but most user-friendly
solution on the market i polled all of
you guys on social media about the best
tools for sleep enhancing sleep and
aidsleep was by far and away the crowd
favorite i mean people were just raving
fans of this so i used it and here we
are add the pod pro cover to your
current mattress and start sleeping as
cool as 55 degrees fahrenheit or as hot
as 110 degrees fahrenheit it also splits
your bed in half so your partner can
choose a totally different temperature
my girlfriend runs hot all the time she
doesn't need cooling she loves the heat
and we can have our own bespoke
temperatures on either side which is
exactly what we're doing now for me and
for many people the result eight sleep
users fall asleep up to 32 percent
faster reduce sleep interruptions by up
to 40 and get more restful sleep overall
i can personally attest to this because
i track it in all sorts of ways it's the
total solution for enhanced recovery so
you can take on the next day feeling
refreshed and now my dear listeners
that's you guys you can get two hundred
and fifty dollars off of the pod pro
cover that's a lot simply go to eight
sleep dot com slash tim or use code tim
that's eight all spelled out e-i-g-h-t
sleep dot com slash tim or use coupon
code tim t-i-m eight sleep dot com slash
tim for 250 off your pod pro cover
this episode is brought to you by tonal
imagine having an entire gym's worth of
equipment in a device smaller than a
flat screen tv something that could fit
potentially even in a closet fits in my
closet by eliminating traditional
weights tonal can deliver 200 pounds of
resistance with a sleek design that can
fit nearly anywhere it's like having an
entire gym and personal trainer right in
your home tonal's patented digital
weight system senses your strength and
adjusts the weight automatically in real
time so you can get the most out of
every workout i have a number of friends
including competitive athletes who have
doubled their strength in short order in
a lot of exercises and part of the
reason that's possible is it uses a
revolutionary system of dynamic
resistance powered by electric motors
for strength you can feel you can also
do things like eccentrics
over time tonal learns from your body
and automatically increases the weight
exactly when you can handle it tonal
also uses 17 sensors to provide
real-time feedback on your form and
technique allowing you to get the most
effective workout every time it's a
strength training machine with
adjustable arms that provides more than
170 exercises for a full body workout
and that can include squats deadlifts
bench presses overhead pulls bicep curls
and more so check it out try tonal the
smartest home gym for 30 days in your
home tonal is so confident that you'll
love it they offer a full money back
guarantee you can now get tonal from 63
dollars per month at zero percent
interest over 48 months
visit
www.tonal that's
com and for a limited time get 100 off
when you use promo code tim 100 at
checkout that's www.tonal.com
promo code tim 100 tim100
tonal be your strongest
at this altitude i can run flat out for
a half mile before my hands start to
shake can i answer your personal
questions
[Music]
hello boys and girls lemurs and
squirrels this is tim ferriss welcome to
another episode of the tim ferriss show
where it is my job to deconstruct
world-class performers from all
different disciplines to tease out the
lessons habits
new tools etc that you can use my guest
today is one of my favorite guests and a
good friend matt mullenweg matt is a
co-founder of the open source publishing
platform wordpress which now powers more
than one-third of all sites on the web
he is the founder and ceo of automatic
m-a-t-t see what he did there automatic
the company behind wordpress.com
woocommerce tumblr wpvip day one and
pocketcasts additionally matt runs
audrey capital can you guess who that's
named after
i'll give you three guesses an
investment and research company he has
been recognized for his leadership by
forbes bloomberg businessweek inc
techcrunch fortune fast company wired it
keeps going vanity fair and the
university philosophical society matt is
originally from houston texas where he
attended the high school for the
performing and visual arts and studied
jazz saxophone in his spare time matt is
an avid photographer i encourage you to
check out
ma.tt
he currently splits his time between
houston and jackson hole for my first
interview with matt way back in 2015
where he had very long hair go to tim
dot blog slash matt there was some
tequila involved as mentioned you can
find him online at m a dot tt you can
find him on twitter at photomat that
tells you just how many photos he's
taken and on instagram at photomat
without further ado please enjoy this
wide-ranging conversation with matt
mullenweg
this is a new acoustic environment for
me
matt mullenweg
we'll get to you in just a minute but
we're sitting here
in a shell tent
which has surprisingly good acoustics
kind of like sitting inside a
spherical
curtain i guess
to deaden the noise or dead in the
echoes and we are on top of
ice
miles of it miles of ice we have two
layers
in this shell tent
and inside we have a little fold out
table on which we have
bluetooth
speaker we have some caffeine
you have some water we have how would
you say this
ah glen meringue
when meringue glenn morangie
going to correct us here
help us out
g-l-e-n-m-o-r-a-n-g-i-e
highland single malt scotch whiskey
legends the cad ball let somebody sort
that out
and then we have a nalgene bottle full
of water
and then we have a nalgene bottle
that is
colored it is orange and the reason that
is orange is this currently
full of 28 ounces of my urine
wow straw opens him yeah and does that
need to be on the table you know this is
a reminder that i need to dispose of it
so if you come to antarctica which is
where we are right now
everything that is brought in needs to
be carried out and that includes all
human waste because if you pee in the
snow here be here for hundreds of years
or thousands of years
and
in such case
you need to if you have to pee when
you're outside or you're in your tent
and you're freezing your ass off and
don't want to walk
to one of the bathrooms you need to pee
into a bottle so that's why i have
a differently colored bottle so i don't
mistakenly assume as you might because
there are no bubbles here this is my
water which i guess it is in some sense
slightly used
so
last time we did a podcast
i guess we were doing some back of the
napkin is what five
years ago five years ago and a lot has
happened in the last five years but
before we get to that
cheers sir cheers
so fun to spend time with you as always
and thanks for coming to antarctica well
thank you for the insight i'm so
excited to finally come
here
for a million reasons the principle of
which is just getting to spend more time
together honestly this is our fifth
continent so we got two more that's
crazy and australia and then we'll we'll
have
patrick we'll have we'll have the hat
trick of all seven
yeah we're day nine now in antarctica
day nine we've been off the internet for
a while which i'm a little shaky
yeah it's like 98 of my brain some
withdrawal symptoms
wait you have to you have to now we're
gonna get to the bio don't worry folks
but so one of your
coping mechanisms
like the methadone
for
the internet addict was downloading what
what did you download
a lot of before you came here downloaded
a good chunk of the wikipedia
the wikipedia like the facebook i like
wikipedia yes definitely and uh well i
remember last i downloaded scrabble
dictionary too i remember last time i
was in antarctica in 2014
it was really just looking stuff up that
i miss the most and um and i've used it
a number of times here and also like i
might have the fullest copy of the
wikipedia
of our group so that's like it came in
handy yeah i wanted to look up a few
factoids about suriname and boom there
it was there was
but then i found out that ernesto hoost
who's one of my favorite kickboxers of
all time was born in suriname
later
won k1 a million times people who know
what that is will know and just long
story to explain
but
there were no accompanying photographs
of course yeah i should say just given
the bandwidth limitations so
here we are day nine
you i guess we're ruminating on what day
it might be and i had no idea because it
is daylight
all the time 24 hours a day and it is so
bright i had experienced 24-hour
twilight once above the arctic circle in
alaska but this is totally different i
mean this is like laying on your back
in santa barbara with the sun beating
down on you at
you know 10 a.m on a perfectly bluebird
day it's so bright all the time
so
everything kind of blends together and
you're not really sure when you should
be tired or shouldn't be tired you think
it's
1 p.m and we came back from an excursion
today and it was already 6 45. something
like that
it's really
strange it's super strange to not have
a circadian rhythm
modulated by
light change to
synchronize to
super weird it's been yeah it feels very
timeless when we've been here and day of
the week everything has been kind of
lost we also had a very special morning
we did so before we get to the morning
matt mullenweg
for people who don't know who are you ah
friend of tim
uh but probably better known for
co-founding open source software called
wordpress which is blogging cms content
management system
has over 50 000 plugins and themes and
i'm the ceo of a company
it's a lot smaller last time we talked
called automatic
there's a mat in there that's kind of a
little pun
and we make wordpress.com the place to
get wordpress woocommerce which is
ecommerce built on top of wordpress
tumblr jetpack all sorts of uh day one
awesome journaling app simple notes
pocket cast for podcasting so check out
pocketcast great up so we uh basically
try to make the open web make the web
more open
and what percentage of the web uses
one of those products or wordpress
itself at this point on the w3 text
wordpress is now up to 42
it's probably like 10 last time we
talked
that's incredible yeah it's it's coming
up and what would you guess five years
ago roughly size of the company then and
now
then we were a couple hundred and now
we're a couple thousand we're coming up
on two thousand people which has
been really amazing distributed before
it was cool yeah
that's worth noting that was kind of a
funny thing as well as i even started a
podcast called distributed and i was
like okay my goal
for the 2020s basically the next 10
years was to get more remote work
happening
it happened sorry about the virus guys
yeah so just woke up one day and you
know of people who could that numbers
were incredible how many people switched
to distributed work
but yeah we've been distributed since
the beginning we're about 2000 people 92
countries
majority of the company first language
is not english and we communicate
primarily asynchronously through
blogging
now when you say blogging you're
referring to internal tools that
resemble blogging yeah we have this tool
called p2 the letter p
as in penguin and the number two
and it's basically an internal blog we
have no email in the company the only
email i get is hr stuff
and uh everything usually i'm guessing
not a good day
i work a lot with hr
um so that will happen privately but
everything else instead of sending an
email will just kind of blog to each
other and so everything has a permalink
everything is archived everything is
searchable and you can have rich in beds
like figment beds youtube embeds it's
not first in bed sigma i don't know what
that is
uh figma is actually an awesome tool you
should check out
imagine a way to coordinate design
online
and in real time so you and i could be
working on the same wireframes or
interaction design and um actually it's
the latest episode of the distributed
podcast and i didn't actually interview
the founder dillon connie yangton mutual
friend of ours who was a designer we owe
connie credit for another prop we have
on the table we may or may not use
which are the holstee h-o-l-s-t-e-e
reflection cards
and there are a lot of
decks of questions
that i've seen out and about and i've
tried quite a few my girlfriend loves
these various decks and there's the good
the bad and the ugly and i'd say mostly
fairly mediocre
and this is a deck that is is quite good
so we might get to some questions here
so connie you were saying interviewed
the founder of figma on the distributed
yeah latest episode it's a cool tool i
think you you might enjoy checking it
out actually i will
figma i'm on it
and
let's see what else
this is such a lazy question but
it kind of boggled my mind to think that
it's been five years
since we last did one of these yeah
because you said what the first episode
we did was number 60 something 61 61
in the bay area at my kitchen table or
dining room table all the same
in
glen park
back when you had
you had your golden locks i think that
was when you still had your goal had
pretty long hair yeah
i tried to change it up every every year
or two every once in a while and uh at
the time
the nectar of choice was tequila and so
that that featured very uh heavily in
more ways than one you're going to just
hoping yeah that was um yeah that was
that's a go-to that was good evening
that was a good evening so this morning
if we switch from evening to morning so
we had a very interesting morning and it
started
well i didn't really ever end i guess i
mean it was continuous most people
didn't sleep but what happened this
morning
so part of the reason we're in
antarctica besides the penguins which i
know you talked a lot about was sue
check out that episode with sioux flood
is the total solar eclipse
that happened here in antarctica
and it's only one in the continent until
2039 i think that's total solar eclipse
so you and i at the wee hours of the
morning very very we
got to see what was my first visible
total solar eclipse and that was
incredible the landscape in antarctica
is so dramatic yeah it's a it's a place
that really makes you feel
it's a very patient landscape and it
makes you feel
like
your size in the cosmos
interesting that you'd use the word
patient why do you use that adjective i
was anticipating you might say vast or
majestic vast even more so than majestic
but why why patient
there's something to me about antarctica
that feels really timeless and also just
unconcerned with
human welfare
utterly welfare and time scales yeah you
know things here happen over huge time
scales and it's so cool
to see like mountains buried by glaciers
essentially like they look like they're
like have a blanket over them and that
was over how many tens or hundreds of
thousands of years it's pretty
incredible it is and we were we were
chatting with a gentleman yesterday i
don't know if he would want to be named
so i won't name him but
he had
mentioned
how deep an impact
i guess his first full totality
as it's known first total solar eclipse
had affected him and how he had always
on some intellectual level understood
our relative insignificance from a
cosmic perspective but the first time
that he viscerally felt that which
actually was deeply therapeutic for him
was seeing a totality with his daughter
in his arms and somebody behind him
caught this amazing photograph of his
daughter tiny little daughter pointing
up at the totality as it's happening i
mean you couldn't have scripted a better
photograph
and
then
this morning it still feels well like it
was two days ago i mean every everything
blurs and blends together which is we've
lived lifetimes we've left lifetimes it
was around what 4 44 i want to say
and
leading up to it in the days leading up
to it
i was looking forward to it but i wasn't
jumping up and down with excitement i
just assumed okay
it gets progressively darker then it's
dark and then it gets progressively
lighter like i'm not
that
blown away by the story phenomenon yeah
yeah cool story bro
and
had to be there had to be there and it
turns out you really do have to be there
and
when it actually started creeping up and
you're watching this happen and you're
observing the progression through these
eclipse glasses
because otherwise you'll blow your eyes
out of course especially if something's
magnified through equipment
and
when it actually
fully overlapped and you're able to take
off your glasses and look at it directly
it
was stunning and the effects on the
horizon and on the visibility of stars
the things happening around it the
shadow bands as people refer to them as
right
traveling across the ground did you see
the wavy ones i did i was so surreal
yeah and
just everything about it
almost hearkened back for me to
prehistoric humanoid times like it
touched something very old if that makes
any sense it felt like it touched
something
in
species or racial memory going back
thousands of years where you can imagine
the impact that this would have on
any
sentient being who's observing it and
really paying attention and watching it
difficult to put into words that was the
most common
sentence probably some variation of that
that i heard afterwards people were
giddy people were euphoric
and
the expression was you just can't put it
into words or i can't put it into words
and i encourage people to look up the
history of eclipses there's been some
cool
historical moments where predicting
eclipse are not predicting eclipse or i
think two kings died after seeing them
and then that was part of the creation
of europe uh yeah
king john the pious you were saying and
then europe was split up into
what essentially became france so it
became italy and what became germany to
his three sons so yeah eclipses
seem to figure pretty strongly into
the shaping of history and the shaping
of national borders what's more reliable
than the sun yeah and for that to be
blotted out for a moment is uh
yeah awe inspiring let's do it again
yeah i don't say this lightly i mean
once it once it happened though i
immediately turned to a few friends that
they were with and i was and i said
i get it i see why people chase this
because we have people here
in this camp because you have these
shell tents
arranged in rows of sorts
and then they have snow piled around
them to brace against the wind and it
does get really really [ __ ] cold here
surprise surprise it's antarctica it's
also very very dry and
people get a lot of sun damage even more
so than it's the driest desert in the
world it is dry it is dry it's part of
the reason you can dry the surface of
say your steak by putting it in a
freezer on an elevated rack for a short
period of time it's the driest place in
your house is a good freezer
so and you just expand that a gazillion
times
we're in a really good freezer over eons
and uh here you are in antarctica it's
also interesting that where we are on
union glacier there's no
birds
no animals no insects literally nothing
living except us
yeah it's i was gonna say disturbingly
but it's not disturbingly it is
oddly quiet
when you go to certain parts of the camp
if you're not within sort of shouting
distance or
within a hearing distance of the mess
hall or something like that and
especially after we spent seven days
with the penguins yeah which have kind
of a constant den yeah and it was really
cute they would walk into camp
and just walk past your tent the tents
have no noise isolated or right up to
the top right after this
actually you're better than noises
that's what he
was that was pretty good thank you you
although that is actually the pairing
call that you hear more at the colony
but they just go
well tim's been practicing this i have
been practicing
much to the chagrin of my travel
traveling companions i've been doing
that like a hundred times a day if you
can cut in some of that field area you
took would be pretty cool oh we will oh
there will be magic in the editing room
[Music]
i have no idea if you'll be able to hear
me or not
but
those are the sounds of thousands of
empire penguins adults
in their
business formal black and white the tire
the
largest of the penguin species so i
would guess i'm no biologist but
probably
let's just call it two and a half to
maybe three and a half feet tall
probably 25 to 45 maybe 25 to 50 pounds
and then they're chicks
who have gray downy feathers or
certainly appear to the adults have i
think
roughly 15
feathers per square centimeter
you're hearing many different calls
and i don't know the meaning
i assume there certainly are meanings of
the different calls but
there is
which they make when they point their
beaks
basically straight down flat against
their chests so i imagine that's
straightening their trachea somehow but
it's the opposite of what you would see
was say
a coyote or a wolf howling
and here i am
holy [ __ ] antarctica
so matt where should we where should we
go next what do you think you want if
you want should we pull out the deck see
what happens should we go somewhere else
are there other things in the last five
years maybe we'll roll into that i mean
five years it seems like so recently
that we
recorded
our other episodes and it's not that
recent i mean it's not it's like if you
live 80
let's just say we live 80 85 years it's
like five years is a meaningful
percentage of that it's true yeah makes
me think of that essay um the great one
from tim urban the tail end yeah which
you introduced me to and i have
shared with so many people
put an edited
or i don't think it was highly edited
but like a slightly
shortened version in i think it was
tools of titans because it had such an
impact on me and that's all thanks to
mr mullen mike
yeah that was one of the big things
since our last episode was my father
passing yeah
you were a great friend through all that
so thank you but
that tell me a lot about this
grief and
the ephemerality of life and everything
so
that was a big one yeah pretty much
everything in my life has changed a lot
in the past five years we hadn't even
acquired woocommerce when we last spoke
and this year it's gonna do
what's the number that we say but i
think 21 billion of transactions
you know we're hoping to do for
e-commerce what we did for websites and
i think there's a chance and the web
wants an open source
thing out there for commerce so
i think what's been exciting for me is
everything is always changing
i'm not good at staying still
everything is always changing not in a
macro world sense so that i guess that's
true you're saying for you personally
yeah you asked me the other day do i
have like a weekly routine where like
mondays or staff meetings tuesdays yeah
if you have an infrastructure for your
week because people like jack dorsey
have talked about this i don't know if
he he does it any longer but i i did ask
you and your answer was every day is
different
and that's part of what keeps it super
exciting for me because i feel like i'm
always learning i know nothing about
podcasting software or journaling
software or e-commerce software or
anything but i love making tools that
people use
it's very very satisfying
if you don't mind let's just come back
for a second to your dad's passing and i
know that was it
understandably extremely tough period
and i don't even know if it's something
you've ever fully metabolized if that's
something you even view in the past
tense it's like something you went
through or if it's something that you
continue to live with but my question is
if there are any
resources
tools books
or just simply advice that you would
give to someone who is
experiencing grief or has lost someone
or maybe is on the cusp of
losing someone yeah
the book that i found most helpful
during that was co-authored by elizabeth
kubler-ross who came up with the
kubler-ross scale i think that's the
five stages denial anger
acceptance of the five stages of grief
the book was called i think grief and
grieving yeah on grief and grieving on
grief and grieving that one was really
powerful might be just grief and
grooming i shouldn't be so definitive
but yeah one of the two yeah so that one
was very very helpful for me but one of
the things i learned was how personal
the process is and how different it is
like for example for me my sister
grieved completely differently
and i've seen other friends go through
this since then and so i would say one
thing i really learned is just that
everyone has their own way of processing
and it'll happen at different times
and it's very easy to get annoyed or mad
or angry or disappointed at how someone
else is grieving if it's different from
yours
how did the book help you what did it
explain or help you to accept or clarify
or otherwise i had heard of those five
stages but i thought they happened
serially like you went in order well
that's what i would assume
and it turns out you you can have them
out of order and multiple ones at the
same time
and in the same day in the same hour
and so that was really helpful
pre-grieving was something i learned a
lot from the book this idea that if you
have a sense that someone's going to
pass there's actually a whole grieving
process that happens
for them
and uh my father was in the hospital for
about five weeks so
that was
one of the most intense periods of my
life and that pre-grieving i hadn't
really understood those those are some
big ones yeah
and it's been
helpful as well i think
especially in american culture we don't
talk about death yeah we don't think
about it we like to pretend it doesn't
happen but it's the one thing that for
certain is going to happen to every
single one of us
and we're all going to lose some only
love and we'll pass someday
and very much like the stoics i think
that
the more you think about it the better
you are able to
handle it yourself and help others when
they're going through it
i have an app for my phone
i think it's
what is it bhutanese it's called my
croak or we croak we croak yeah i've
used we croak and five times a day it
just sends you a notification it's like
just a reminder we're all gonna die
gives you a quote and then it gives you
a quote that you can open app
that one's been yeah i've kept that
going yeah i also um i think we might
have talked about this before but on my
chrome new tab i sort of calculated the
average number of days i'm probably
going to live so every time i open a new
tab has a countdown is that some that's
something you did manually or is that
something other people can do reasonably
easily yeah use a tab thing called
momentum
which allows you to customize your new
tab screen and it can do countdowns and
so i think the date was something like
2060
2000 uh january 11th i picked my
birthday and then it just counts down
and so that's also really interesting
and i find also a good interrupt to
remind me when i'm starting a new tab
which is usually the beginning of
distraction or something
totally that
that it just has memento mori and the
countdown
do you
find that you
begin to tune that out so i've used
momentum i like it a lot but do you end
up at some point becoming
immune to the reminder
have you experienced that or not so much
is there anything you do to prevent that
yeah definitely
develop like a selective blindness to it
i was actually just thinking today like
if i just used every app on my home
screen regularly yeah my life would
probably be much better you know i've
got calm and fitbot and all these sorts
of things that i put on like smart mats
thoughtful mats smartmap put that on the
thinking of your future yeah but i'll
still scroll the four screens over to
get to twitter or instagram or something
oh yeah it's hard to win that one
outgunned as we are
[Applause]
[Music]
i actually deleted all apps from my
phone excuse me that would not make any
sense that make my phone very hard to
use deleted all social apps from my
phone about a year and a half ago
and
haven't installed haven't reinstalled
any of them
and it's been
liberating in some ways and also
frustrating and others to see
how addictive these tools are and how i
will
find workarounds by using i mean the
browser yeah the browser right and
it provides a hurdle right so it's like
the candy isn't within reach like i have
to like open a door and walk through to
another room metaphorically speaking to
get the candy but still
i end up as you've seen on this trip
with the uh
chocolate covered almonds
it's amazing how much chocolate covered
elements tim has consumed
so horrifying so horrifying let's say a
good reminder we're all human even like
four hour body timbers definitely even
for us especially for our bodies
once he goes off the rails it's it's
very very off the rails
oh man so anything else you'd like to
add within the context of the last last
five years
and one more thing on the on the parents
is one thing i wish is that i had more
recordings my dad
just remembering his voice or
even some video though people are more
self-conscious about video so i think
it's great if there's people you love
do something like this have a
conversation with them yeah record it i
think it's uh something you'll both
probably appreciate well you've been
part of the
a big part of the impetus for me to
set
time aside and schedule time to do this
with my parents we had it scheduled and
then there were some calendar and travel
issues of course with covet and
everything else going on but that is
something that i'm planning on doing in
the next few months
and
i'm looking forward to it
i think they're at different points i've
had various reservations but
as i think more and more about kids
i think it becomes it dawns on me
more and more
clearly how valuable
or how treasured that could be at some
point to have that yeah
and just what
our parents our loved ones might
remember about our life is so different
from sometimes what we remember yeah it
could be really enlightening sometimes
yeah because memory is so fallible right
yeah super fillable so it's interesting
to see the different perspectives on it
and triangulate maybe how we turned out
the way we did or things that might have
been very influential on us
so question for you then any
recommendations for my conversations
with my parents are there any particular
types of questions that you would ask
or angles of inquiry or
anything at all no fly zones
anything that comes to mind
you know this is where being offline is
gonna get us what's the the project it's
like on npr where they interview people
there's an app for it
story core story core story and then
c-o-r-p-s
all right and i think they even have an
app with questions and part of what they
do is try to get an oral history
of americans ugh people around the
country
i don't know anything about this but
people can record their own and they
have a really great set of questions
that kind of walk people through amazing
their life history so story core those
would be the experts and check it out
maybe some things that could be a good
framework i will and for what it's worth
since we're talking about recording
we can just mention briefly what i have
right here in front of us which is the
sophisticated grand podcasting studio of
tim ferriss enterprises which is very
very very simple it turns out there's
only been a few minor changes since our
recording five years
ago and the first recording being number
61 of the podcast now we have whatever
it is close to 600 episodes so we've got
the
zoom
h6 recorder in front of me and then we
have two
xlr cables one going to a handheld mic
for matte another going to handheld mic
in my hand
one of the upgrades that i made is when
i do
in-person recording i have two different
color the default is going to be black
cabling i get colored cables
so for video this would be horrible on
the eyes but
practically for recording it's great
because it makes it very easy for me to
see which levels i need to adjust oh
cool that's why the cables are different
colors so we have yellow and orange
and
then i have rechargeable batteries
which are
panasonic rechargeable bqcc55
is going to probably take you to the
proper
make and model
and then we have an iphone with a sure
mv8
microphone that that attaches to the
iphone
through a lightning
port
and captures really good audio so we
have that running as backup
and then the handheld mics are also sure
and i usually use sm58 mics these are
slightly better for voice
and if i could just see yours for a
second this is the
ksm8
and uh they're very nice work really
really well and that's it and it this
all fits into
this mac can tell you hey well there's a
small bag but it all fits into a bagna
hat i have a russian sauna hat
that is perfect padding and installation
for
the recorder itself then everything else
fits easily easily easily into a
backpack you could probably fit most of
it into a big jacket
and you can record anywhere you've now
recorded two in antarctica which is
amazing
it is kind of amazing and so we've had
200 plus degrees fahrenheit with rick
rubin the incredible
music producer although he does a lot
more
in his sauna because that was a
condition for doing this
it was so hot and uh hilariously so
because we ended up having to take
breaks and do ice baths and the mics got
so hot that was one thing we didn't
budget for i was so worried about the
recorder
being damaged or going non-functional
that i didn't pay attention to the
simple fact that when you have the mic
at body height in the sauna it's going
to get ripping hot wow so the equipment
was fine on the floor but the mics got
so hot we had to wrap them in towels
and do it that way so we've done like
plus 200 degrees and with wind chill
probably at
i think they were saying it was negative
35 negative 90 yeah this morning yeah
negative 35 maybe even a little bit
colder the negative 35 maybe a little
bit colder
at gould bay
there we had an open sided tent with
wind
ripping through and a table made of ice
instead of this nice fold-out table
why didn't you close the door at the
tent it was a lounge that had been
created by the staff and one was like up
over the top
and i suppose we could have closed it
but we were all wrapped up and
reasonably cozy i took a picture of you
off the show that's right that's right
yes you have a good photo
just a quick thanks to one of our
sponsors and we'll be right back to the
show this episode is brought to you by
wealthfront did you know if you missed
10 of the best performing days after the
2008 crisis you would have missed out on
50 percent five zero percent of your
returns don't miss out on the best days
in the market stay invested in a
long-term automated investment portfolio
wealthfront pioneered the automated
investing movement sometimes referred to
as robo-advising and they currently
oversee 20 billion dollars of assets for
their clients wealthfront can help you
diversify your portfolio minimize fees
and lower your taxes takes about three
minutes to sign up and then wealthfront
will build you a globally diversified
portfolio of etfs based on your risk
appetite and manage it for you at an
incredibly low cost wealthfront software
constantly monitors your portfolio day
in and day out so you don't have to they
look for opportunities to rebalance and
tax loss harvest to lower the amount of
taxes you pay on your investment gains
their newest service is called autopilot
and it can monitor any checking account
for excess cash to move into savings or
an investment account they've really
thought of a ton they've checked a lot
of boxes smart investing should not feel
like a roller coaster ride let the
professionals do the work for you go to
wealthfront.com tim and open a
wealthfront investment account today and
you'll get your first five thousand
dollars managed for free for life that's
wealthfront.comtim wealthfront will
automate your investments for the long
term and you can get started today at
wealthfront.com
tim
would you mind opening the non-p bottle
so i can have some of the water i'm
pleased that they have the color coding
and i'm going to
open this deck and come a long way from
casa dragonas
by the way yeah cheers let me uh let me
do that with the booze
how much would you give me to drink a
swig of that urine right now
what would what would you trade i i like
you too much tim
i wouldn't do that you know i have
actually i have
i don't know how this came about but i
ended up this is only for you my fine
listeners
no such thing as tmi
however at some point i don't know what
it was built in without tmi kit that was
good that was good so let me take a
break from the p bottle i'm gonna come
back to drinking my own urine story
matt is the master of what
is known in japanese
is like
pops it's like saying dad but in a
really informal way and then gyagu is
gag
and
as it turns out cross-culturally
dads love puns and wordplay
so like if the shitty pun comes up
uh and and often did in my host family
when i was 15 in japan
then the host brother would be like
and
matt is the master so yeah you can't
spell you can't split in without tmi
that is actually very very good that's
very very good
i did take in that same apartment in san
francisco i remember at one point
just deciding you know what i think i
should sample my own urine for what
reason i can't recall and i did and
you've seen how much water i consume so
it's actually totally fine it was it was
it was totally fine
it wasn't over saturated with b vitamins
or anything that will affect the taste i
suspect not that i've had many samplings
but uh i will say i don't make a regular
practice of drinking my urine or do i
recommend it this is not medical advice
it's actually pretty stupid uh as a
story to begin with but you did it so
others don't have to i did it so others
don't have to yeah it wasn't the most
delicious thing i've ever had
all right so let me let me offer you
you want me to choose a card or you want
to choose a card all right go for it all
right
so let's see and you can always refuse
hey would you say your recordings in
antarctica have been intense
intense
is that another pun
oh
intense
oh my god that was so bad sorry that was
intense
you know
true fact as my friend kelly starrett
likes to say
true fact a true fact tim ferriss uh
here's one
what is one fear you would like to
conquer hmm
you're gonna answer the same one
i can or you could use another one
yeah i think that'd be it'd be fun if we
both answered it let's do it because
maybe we'll inspire a different way of
thinking about it in each other great
you know i have a hang up
around
body issues
and
exercise and stuff
and it kind of got
bigger in like the past six months
and as i'm 37 now oh not there old man
young old we first turned mullenweg and
um yeah i think that's a fear i'd like
to conquer because it's totally
irrational
what is the fear exactly
i don't know how to articulate it but
there's something where
[Music]
i don't know how to articulate it
because it's it's a fear it's not it's
not rational it's not something i could
put into words well i mean there are a
lot of fears that are rational right so
just because it's a fear doesn't
automatically make it irrational i think
this is probably a irrational one yeah
all right um yeah something around
it's like an insecurity i'm not gonna
let you go so is it an insecurity around
appearance
i think it's something
yeah something about
i'm sorry i don't know how to go deeper
we can this is this is where i should do
do some heavy lifting or help do some
heavy lifting
what would be an example of a time when
it shows up for you
the resistance i feel around
sort of exercise
that's been growing i would say
where
it's
it shows up like a fear in that
i can think of so many
excuses why including like i'm going to
injure myself again or i'm going to hurt
my knee or
my wrists are bad right now so i
shouldn't be doing this or like things
like that but which really just add up
to be a bunch of excuses
what do you think that is protecting you
from
like if you did not have
because it seems like
that you're a smart guy
so there's probably some part of you not
to like go too far into like ifs dick
schwartz type stuff but like your
subconscious is trying to protect you
from something
potentially
what is it protecting you from what do
you think it is
i don't know i mean it could be injury
right it could be
performing below your expectations
perhaps like if you exercise that you're
not going to meet some standard you've
set for yourself in your mind i have no
idea
[Music]
so it sounds like a it's a hesitancy
that you can't fully explain
therefore it's kind of falling into the
category of fear for you yeah okay how
about for you what's a fear you would
like to overcome
man how much time do we have
i i don't i think that's a bit of an an
overstatement but i
i mean
[ __ ] if we're drinking
drinking our single malt and really
going for it i would say
the fear that i am just hardwired
and
also just software coded through dna to
be depressed and unhappy and that
that is a baseline i cannot escape like
there is the gravitational pull to
out-of-the-box settings is so strong
that no matter what i do no matter how
many morning routines i tweak no matter
how much i exercise no matter how much i
program meticulously
different areas of my life the
regression to the mean is always going
to be to a place of
depression or
this is a strong word like self-loathing
something that is not quite
self-loathing
at a 10 out of 10 intensity but like a
discontent and disappointment with
myself
that's actually that locked in something
about mine which is like a fear of being
bigger
yeah my family's bigger
bigger meaning i feel like like obese
yeah like i have some pre-built settings
the proclivity towards that yeah
hmm
do you believe that
that's your do i overcome that or
depends on the day depends on whether
i've had a good stretch or a bad stretch
or
an average stretch
i mean
even if it is deluding myself i want to
believe that it is
something i can overcome i don't see
how the alternative plays out
is terrifying to me
if i truly truly believe that 100 of the
time
the consequences of that are like
staggeringly scary
so
i don't want to believe that but
if i were a scientist just looking at
the data set i'd be like yeah like if
we're if we're rating days like negative
two negative one zero plus
one plus two
somewhat like jim collins does if people
want more on that you can just listen to
the first conversation i had with him
but
i would say i probably average out
negative one
just on emotional tone the gestalt of
the day being sort of
positive energy
not in that way nothing interesting to
do
around it i should do it also because i
do think and my girlfriend has certainly
pointed this out and i i recognize it as
true that i have a
negative selection bias i think a lot of
humans have negative selection bias
because you get rewarded by overreacting
to
threats what's it what's the stat you
feel a dollar you lose seven times more
than a dollar you gain or keep
yeah i mean they've done studies around
this yeah like how hard would you work
to make a hundred dollars versus how
hard would you work to avoid having like
100 stolen or taken from you right
yeah so
that is one of my macro fears tied to
that would be a fear i don't know if
people can hear that because there's no
there are no birds there's no insects
the footsteps on the snow are like
definitely like
the foot traffic is so loud which makes
it even harder to sleep around here
where was i going or was i uh macro fear
it's related yeah that is related is
that i will never have enough energy
so yeah and i think
some of that ties back to undiagnosed
lyme when i was a kid which has been
verified because i then later had
confirmed lime and i grew up on long
island where it's very very very common
and when i was properly diagnosed after
very severe symptoms the second time
which was i don't know 2012 or 13 or 14
when they did the elisa i think it's the
at least a blot test and other testing
they gave me my results and the first
thing they said was well you realize
that you've had lyme disease before
right wow because i was showing i guess
the long-term antibodies like the
serologic testing
i might not be getting the details right
but suffice to say i had already had
lyme but it had gone undiagnosed which
meant it was untreated for
a long long time so i don't know how
much to attribute to that versus a
family history of depression versus
other things but i've always struggled
with
energy levels so i was like the currency
in which i am poorest
and it doesn't matter how much time you
have tension or otherwise like if you
don't have just the battery
to execute
you are sol
[ __ ] people who listen to your podcast
would guess that about you
i don't think so because
they're getting one percent of my time
not one percent but it's like i don't
spend all of my time recording
conversations yeah right so they get to
hear me
when i'm having fun usually right like i
enjoy the podcast like it is very deeply
nourishing
to me and
when it starts to feel anything other
than that i change something right like
i decrease the frequency and like i
could do it three times four times five
times a week but it would start to feel
like a burden or a chore and i don't
want that to be the case so i don't
think most people would guess that you
know you did share with me i don't know
if you're willing to share here or want
to share here that you um got a lot of
comfort from
a revelation
oh was this the existential piece yeah
yeah i'm willing to share this is a
weird one so
this kind of ties into another fear
which is
i don't know if it's a fear it's a
belief the consequences of which are
really
unpleasant although i've started to look
at it in a slightly different way and
i'll back into it by saying like i think
meaninglessness can be
terrifying but in a way it can also be
liberating because it frees you to kind
of do
whatever you choose to pursue and
over the last year
we've been talking about this on this
trip i
think
we agree on a lot of things
one not trivial very non-trivial thing
that i think we have differing opinions
on is just like inherent human nature
right i have a i don't want to call it
dystopian but
i tend to think we are closer to chimps
than not right like like one percent
you know exactly yeah nasty root of
shorts
nasty brutus short right hobsian is the
right way to put it
and i'm a little more pinker-esque you
know better angels over nature yeah
exactly so in as such
i have been involved
in a bunch of things over the last
handful of years
including
psychedelic therapeutics especially on
the non-profit research side i haven't
done any for profit
investments myself
and you've been a huge supporter of that
world as well so thanks for that thank
you it's a big deal and
then also with different conservation
work in the amazon and north america and
so on and
have just run into what i view as this
kind of
i know i know one could argue against
but like almost for me like an
irrefutable truth just based on
overwhelming evidence that i've faced
over and over again that like humans
cannot resist pissing in the pool like
they can't help themselves like they're
so competitive and driven by incentives
which of course all animals are
and it has been
for me i have
i'll make it active right like i have
depressed myself
and upset myself so i'll make it
transitive here right so that i have
some agency
to repeatedly run into what i view as
like
unavoidable self-destructive
tendencies
which on smaller scales aren't
necessarily self-destructive but at
larger scales with billions and billions
of people become just untenable
i was just like what's the point i found
it very difficult to
get up and muster any kind of enthusiasm
or motivation to like knock out these
email about various
just like [ __ ] items that might be
very interesting but i'm like okay i'm
gonna like invest in some like whatever
the [ __ ] app that does something that
really isn't
making a dent and like what's the point
of all this because like ultimately
we're all like just careening towards
this incineration that i don't see is
particularly avoidable
and then i was reading this book which
does punch the four hour kick in the
balls a little bit which i found kind of
funny honestly so it does make a
reference to the four hour work week and
not in terribly kind way which is fine
because what do you expect if you title
a book four hour work week but
the book also has a four in the title
but it's called four thousand weeks that
refers to the average lifespan of humans
and there's actually a lot of great
exploration in this book looking at the
frailty and the fallacies of time
management and productivity
and the kind of to-do list obsession and
optimization of different types
and
one of the chapters
i think is called something like cosmic
insignificance
therapy
which i think this morning was a great
example of where
you actually find it liberating to
realize how much
it doesn't matter so you end up finding
it kind of inspiring and freeing instead
of debilitating and crushing
which is i find hard to do because i
tilt towards the darkness and so the
realization was like well okay look even
if people are
just hell-bent on self-destruction and
we head that way
at the end of the day
our
son is going to
red giant white dwarf
kablue
and then the earth is gone anyway all
life on earth is gone at that point or
as certainly as far as i know all life
on earth so even if like we kill our own
species and all sorts of other species
off on this planet the life per se of
earth is finite regardless and i was
like oh actually
that brings some peace to me sunshine
tim yeah it's yeah i mean god this
sounds so depressing but
like this is kind of
a lot of the [ __ ] that i think about in
part because
i know this is supposed to be me asking
you questions we're going to get to
another question but it's like
i don't know if you've experienced
because like you didn't grow up rich i
didn't grow up rich
and
at least for me
in my group of friends and their
families growing up like lower middle
class it was like if only we had money
our problems would be solved like here
are these problems if we just had money
it doesn't grow on trees and like oh
that rich person wouldn't that be nice
everything is
smooth as gravy over there i am sure
and then you pursue your pursuit you
pursue and you can kind of
push your issues to the side
in pursuit of
becoming quote unquote successful
because the assumption underlying it is
when i have x or y or z whatever that
amount is then i'll be happy then i'll
be happy and then you like then you like
run through
one of those finish lines and you're
like
well wait a [ __ ] second like this is
a false bill of lading that didn't work
at all
and uh
which you know by the way when some
people ask like what
would you change or emphasize if you
wrote the four hour work week again it's
the filling the void chapter
which is a chapter that people kind of
skip over because it's not this like
hyper practical tactical
nuts and bolts chapter but it's really
important so
yeah that's my very very very long
rambling
answer to the existential realization
which is like oh yeah this planet's got
a finite lifespan anyway as far as like
organic life goes so and that's
something i always find interesting is
sometimes relief from what seems like
existential problems they come from the
most unusual places yeah and so i was
surprised that this came
for you that that was a
comforting thought but i do i do
believe in the cosmic
insignificance you know it's very
humbling to think like our time span
even all of human recorded history is
just a speck of dust of the universe's
time span
yeah and um
one thing i really appreciate about you
tim
is that you engage
with
work and thinkers
that some people might assume are the
opposite of you
or advocate for different things but
it's all part of your your growth and
your journey and like firming up things
so i like that you wouldn't read this
book and how cool that it provided this
relief for you you know yeah thanks man
it's a solid book and uh the way that i
parsed it online was i put it on
i guess twitter and i said
for people who have read this such and
such book you know four thousand weeks
how much would you recommend it to a
friend
from one to ten no seven allowed
which is something i learned from a
person named kyle maynard because it
forces people to like
pick a barely passing or
pretty strong recommendation at eight
and the vast majority of recommendations
are the vast majority of answers and
there could be selection bias obviously
right
people read the book in the first place
yeah exactly came back at like 9
8 9 10 the vast majority uh
which was certainly enough
to convince me to get it on kindle and
read a few chapters and i end up liking
it a lot i mean
in just because i can't i can't resist
just a little jab
the author does use a lot of like 10
words where a 10 cent word would work
so
i think i'm pretty well educated but i
still had to look some words up
it's okay he apparently punched a
four-hour work week
he did punch the work week in the nuts
but that's okay because uh you know get
in line
so how many years has it been since four
hour work week
it's published in april of 2007
so 14 14.
it's
it's a teenager it's a teenager going to
college it's starting high school it's
going to college years yeah it's
incredible
let's try another card let's try another
card
all right so you want me to read this
one first
oh god it's more no that's a fierce one
here i'll let you choose
and uh let me just
grab a few cards off the top and again
for people interested i don't even know
if these are made anymore because i
recall them being sold out or
discontinued at some point holsty
h-o-l-s-t-e-e
reflection cards i got these on amazon
dealer's choice there's choice and
what's the light and dark side mean is
one a tougher question
yes the darker
half of the card is intended to be a
more difficult question
it's not always the case but that's what
it's intended to be if a crystal ball
could tell you the truth about your life
the world or anything else what would
you want to know
i think you should answer that first
because i just finished a ted talk
[Laughter]
what would i want to know
i'd want to know what is before life and
afterlife
i have this i had the same answer really
yeah
the same answer yeah it's it's one of
those things i think it's very difficult
to truly know and it's very difficult
yeah
it's something humanity's grappled with
in a million different ways for
probably as long as we've been conscious
and um
yeah curious about that
i need more met you got to do more than
just whispered me about generalities
more about what's interesting about the
afterlife or the free life uh
yeah either either both end i would say
what
this is this is obviously a big one but
like what do you
if you had to speculate what do you
think happens
i mean if you want to go with pre-birth
we could do that that's definitely a
unusual way to approach it but well it's
one i think why i thought of that is
because
i've done meditations before where they
say like
feel what it was like before you were
born
that's what it'll be like after you're
you're done so like meditations on death
and so yeah in theory there's something
before if there's something after right
yeah i'm going to plug two books here
plug away
annika harris consciousness
yep this is four theories of
consciousness after our conversations on
this trip like that it's absolutely on
my to read list
great book and i think it kind of gets
this question
of pre-life and afterlife as well
because
where does the consciousness come from
when does it start where does it go
how is it suspended
one where they're suspended
yeah
it's such such an interesting what turns
it on and off yeah what does it even
really mean and this book is a a
fantastic kind of and brief
um so very dense uh densely packed or
very valuable i'd say not longer than it
needs to be a book
and then david eagleman who
this is some yeah
so good have we talked about that
was it i maybe you recommended it to me
it might have been i think i did one of
your books i recommend thing ah
yeah
books i've loved yeah and uh four
details of after lives and each one
starts basically at the moment of death
and then it's uh
it's kind of something that happens
afterwards and they're hilarious and
it's a great bedtime read yeah so i like
to read short chapters like three to two
to five pages yeah and it's nice to
break it up nightly and some of them
i've even read aloud to friends when
you're a burning man i did it as a gift
i would read
one of these short stories to people
some of my favorites are
the scent of species
that's really great and um and the
opening one sum is actually pretty fun
can you give a teaser so
i think it'd be helpful to give people
an example since each of these short
chapters
is a hypothetical
manifestation of the afterlife
so what what might one be so the opener
some and i'll tell a little without
giving away that amazing ending
you relive life but serially so all the
things that you did at different points
broken up in your life you do all the
same time so you shower for like 80
hours
you sleep for 30 years you cut your
nails for like you know you're trying to
remember a word for like two days
you're standing in line for you know 14
days and so it kind of goes through this
almost laundry list of it yeah and um
yeah beautiful ending it
is a great book it is an exceptional
book after plugging these two books
what do you think what happens
or it doesn't happen
unplugged computer light's out that's it
i'm looking forward to finding out some
day not too soon but
you said you had the same answer so wait
which answer
oh
yeah well i just think it would help
i do think and maybe i'd be open to a
counter argument but i do think it would
just help you decide how to
spend your time
better in
this particular iteration if it's the
one and only
thank you getting a little boost from a
flask
classy or classy
and
i mean it would answer so many
questions right i think the interesting
thing was would humans truly be
different
what do you mean by that
would they how would they act
differently if we had a defensive answer
one a lot of people think they do have a
definitive answer that's kind of the
basis of many religions and things so
it's not unusual
and
you know a lot of people
you could say that how had anthony
demelo put it they're not truly living
yeah right they need to wake up they
need to pay attention yeah and that's
even though they might think there's
this happening in the afterlife or
well if you knew for sure though i mean
let's just say it's like all right
hellfire and brimstone
that's one thing right sins in the whole
nine yards
purgatory yeah like the judeo-christian
model but then if you had
say karma and you're like reincarnated
as a
hamster or a porpoise or a
demi-god depending on your behavior then
that would that would certainly well you
would think would affect some choices
right if you knew what happened
afterwards definitively it would also
affect how you viewed things this is
going to get dark folks sorry but like
things like suicide right so the stoics
didn't have a particularly negative view
of suicide but then once you get into
the judeo-christian
lens
it is most certainly negative right
and
that is one of many different things
that would be clarified if you knew i
mean if you were just simply zeroing out
a character like ready player one
yeah that's one thing right insert coin
uh but would that make people less
responsible the lives they have right
now
define responsible reckless careless
because they thought they could just
insert another coin and play again well
if they knew they could then it wouldn't
be reckless yeah i think um that's an
interesting area of of thought and it
also reminds me of something i think
which i hope expands a lot in the coming
years is um ethical assisted euthanasia
yeah people end of life with waiting
periods and all these sorts of things i
know hawaii is a place where you can do
it
and a few different countries yeah going
back to some
seen people pass away yeah past five
years
i understand why some people might
choose to do that if they have a
terminal illness illness or something
yeah
interesting we had the same answer
and not all together completely
unsurprising
oh boy that's a good one
can i tell you what i'd like it to be
what you would like your answer to be
yeah yeah afterlife um oh well you'd
like the afterlife to be okay i think
it'd be kind of cool if
our brains are like antennas to some
deeper consciousness
and we reconnected with it sort of went
back to that non-dual nature
of enlightenment you mean like a drop of
the ocean returning to the ocean type
situation yeah
i i find that comforting
yeah i do too
all right here's one
i got one for you if you knew that in
one year you would die suddenly would
you change anything about the way you
are living now
why i'm going to modify that question if
you knew that in one year you would die
suddenly what would you change about the
way you are living now why hmm which is
nicely related to our previous comments
what i would change
well what i did change after that tail
end essay
was spending more time with loved ones
if i knew i had one year
gosh i've got so much left to do
you know what's funny is let's assume
it's perfect health for a year and then
just lights up yeah
i think i would this is kind of a funny
answer i wouldn't have thought of this
before but i'd write more you'd write
more
i did not see that coming tell me more
it brings up for me like what's the
legacy how do i pass on the things i
care about like democratizing publishing
in the web
to the generations that are going to
carry the torch there
and how much of
what motivates me towards that lifelong
mission around open source
i don't know if i've written about
particularly well or articulated well
that in a way that might inspire others
and wordpress is open source has
tens of thousands of contributors so
like there are a good number of people
involved but
i like yeah i feel like for open source
to truly win we need millions of
contributors we need most of the world
working on it because the alternative is
proprietary
bad for humanity things so yeah i think
i'd write and really try to write
something that
or write as much as possible things to
bring more people contributing to open
source
tell me more what else
if anything else
i think that's really because that's my
life mission it really is
and so if my life was ending i think how
do i keep that mission going i'm so
envious of you
that that is so clear
i don't think most people
could sit here i can't and say x is my
life mission
that's pretty [ __ ] amazing i mean
thank you well i i i mean it is just it
just seems so i feel very lucky it's
liberating to have that
defined that can i want to say
constraint but not in a bad way right
like you've
kind of defined
the target in the bullseye
in such a way that makes i would think
it makes decision making
like your decision fatigue must be less
if that's clear
does really help
really helps clarify things
you know that and the memento mori yeah
i do feel like i have momento mori being
meditating on death and the finite
nature of 14 000 days give or take a
couple hundred
left to try to move this
you know mission forward as much as
that's to death right that's not
necessarily
firing on all cylinders
yeah i feel like i'm going to keep
working until i croak
yeah
yeah it also you know sometimes it's
really hard and there's days and weeks
and months where the job wordpress
automatic everything can be very very
challenging and also helps keep it going
but i will say that it probably
i think you do have that actually me
yeah oh please
pray tell please fill me in
well how do you spend your time
oh my god this is gonna be doing things
like this
yeah yeah and why do you do it why do
you share it why don't you keep all this
amazing information for yourself
because it's too
i mean it sounds so
self-aggrandizing i mean i just i think
that's
it's too humanizing and valuable to keep
private if it's so easy to make public
that gets
nourishing to me number one
and
i
know how much conversations like this i
mean if you and i were sitting here with
no mics
bullshitting and drinking
glitter
single malt scotch whiskey
we'd be having a similar conversation
anyway you know what i mean we've had
lots of these we've had lots of nine
days yeah and
the reason i started the podcast because
i'd be having these conversations with
friends they would end and i'd be like
god what a waste like it would be so
that conversation was so helpful to me
i have to imagine it would be helpful to
other people i think that
drive to share
to learn and share which i've seen
the entire
10 plus years i've known you
is a life mission i can't imagine you
ever stopping that yeah i can't either
like you're going to be in an old
person's home be like i figured out this
new way to like move the wheelchair like
look what i can do like
this is like just something that so i
think you do have that and i think you
should play with that maybe or you know
find what words resonate for you
and describing that around that learning
and sharing because i do think do you
think you'll do this the rest of your
life some form of this
but like oh yeah yeah some form of this
i mean i i just
when people ask me like how long do you
think you'll do the podcast i'm like i
can't it's the first thing i've done
this consistently
over an extended period of time and
i can't think of a compelling reason
for why i would stop right which is
another reason why
even though i've had a bunch of
conversations i haven't
seriously considered i mean you'll
obviously support this i think
doing anything that would put me in a
walled garden
because it's just it's so kind of
antithetical if i were to sacrifice
a large part of my reach or distribution
it just doesn't make sense right like to
have shackles on in any form or fashion
would like suck the soul out of what i'm
doing which is not to say there couldn't
be interesting collaborations with large
platforms or companies
but to make any sacrifice
on the creative side or the editorial
freedom side or anything like that just
wouldn't make any sense so
and you would do it even if you made no
money
yeah you would pay to do it you do pay
to do it i do pay so this is something
something around that i think uh the
interesting fear to find out because i
can't imagine ever growing stopping
learning and then not sharing it to
whoever will listen to you
so you do that i'll democratize
publishing in the web
and commerce and i think that'll be fun
yeah
one year one year is really short it's a
short period of time
you know
you think about the last year
interminably long and also
unbelievably short at the same time yeah
and
yeah i think for me
i don't know if she'd be game for this
but probably having kids
with my girlfriend
like just to at least i mean god it's
depressing to think about but
also incredible to think about like just
being there for the birth like for a few
months and then
adios amigo off i go
um but to have that experience i think
that would be core to the next to the
remaining year
uh i remember uh
i don't know if he'd want his name
mentioned but a very famous scientist
and i were chatting at one point and he
mentioned having a kid pretty late in
life
and his brother the first thing his
brother said to him was congratulations
and welcome to the human race he was
like you just
and uh you know we chatted about that
quite a bit
but it just seems
so
on some level i'm not saying it's
required but like fundamental to a lot
of obviously human existence right
they're programming
pointed towards procreation yeah that's
incredible how strong that drive is yeah
and it's like you talk to people who
like
they they have the most incredibly
sophisticated rationalizations and at
the end of the day it's like you're just
doing what you're programmed to do and
maybe there's a beauty in that maybe
there's a real beauty in
kind of just fulfilling that like yeah
you're a cutter ant you carry [ __ ]
leaves around and you build [ __ ] and
you're
gigantic you know hand calling and like
that's just what you do and
i have to imagine like it feels good to
them to do that or at least it would
feel bad for them not to do that
it's interesting you bring that up
because that's something that changed
for me in the past five years
yeah okay wow if we're willing to go
there let's let's go there
after my father passed i really
decided i went down the path of like
okay
have a kid yeah
and i think part of that was just
thinking oh i wish he had known
a grandchildren a grandchild or
something
and
part of that process was later
deciding that that's not going to be
how i leave an impact on the world
and so i i decided to not have kids yeah
and made that a very explicit
communication and everything like that
because wordpress and this other work
i'm doing i want to be the thing that i
i leave
and
i don't feel like there's anything
particularly good about my genetics that
needs to be passed on or that i would be
a world unique
parent
but i do think i'm i'm one of the people
in the world that does have a chance to
shape the future of the web
and uh
i just want to focus all of my energy
into that
where would you put
if you were a betting man which of
course you are we're all betting people
we're all placing bets like everything's
probability
except for death and taxes i guess
maybe a few other things
where would you put the likelihood that
that changes
i think you had an answer in mind when
you asked me that
i no this is this is not a leading
question i'm just curious yeah
and
as a guy we do have some more
optionality yep
around these things
you know never say never
but that is
that is my working
sort of software and firmware right now
okay
so let's say i'll say 20 chance 20 20
shots maybe less maybe less than i'd say
eight percent chance eight oh wow that's
very precise i like that eight percent
so next five years
child being born eight percent yeah
i [ __ ] love that
that's gonna be
that's gonna be the headline of this
podcast episode
[Laughter]
oh wow you wanna try another one do you
wanna yeah let's see give it a go
wow this is actually a question you ask
all the time which is kind of funny we
won't do that one no that's funny what
message would you put on a billboard for
thousands people to see every day i did
not get it from this deck but yes that
is a question that i do ask
don't drink your piss because i said it
on a podcast that's what i would put on
my board
okay here we go
what are two things oh still on your
bucket list
god you know part of me we've had enough
whiskey i just want to mention all these
like
ridiculous sexual fantasies but we're
not going to get there
we need uh it's just just you and me and
our few million of my best friends
listening
let's see
two on the bucket list
i'm not gonna count the kid
because that's
we've already discussed it so i'm gonna
i'm gonna put that out of bounds
i might need some time to think about
that which is actually disturbing to me
that i need time to think about it does
anything immediately come to mind for
you
yeah you know what once it comes to mind
what's that could be a fun trip for us
to do actually is the um aurora borealis
so actually this comes full circle you
will like this and i think i've told you
this but
man i'm sorry that it was of course
catalyzed by the passing of your father
but you recommend the talent to me
and i'm with you during this i mean not
with you but we're in contact during
this entire process
i read the talent i go holy [ __ ] [ __ ]
and by the way everybody just look up
the tail end tim urban and read it do
yourself a favor
and so i made a commitment to
take my family on a trip once a year
and we haven't done it in the last two
years
but the
i think it was the first trip my mom had
always wanted to see the aurora borealis
i took my whole family to iceland
and went to the middle of nowhere
in the middle of winter it's dark all
the time so it's the opposite of what
we're experiencing right now
and we had the best luck
ever and we just saw the most incredible
displays of the aurora borealis and i
have to say
much like what we experienced this
morning you cannot
currently capture it at all on
video or camera it just it doesn't
bear any resemblance to the feeling and
the experience of doing it in person so
i would definitely do that again i was
actually looking for it this morning
because while the totality is happening
you can actually see stars yeah uh when
the sun's totally covered by the moon
and um there's a different word for the
southern borealis i think or southern or
but um yeah there's a chance we could
have seen it wonder what that's called
the aurora borealis the austral borealis
i'm making up words now this is we don't
have the internet yeah the internet
we're hobbled does that be one thing on
the bucket list does that remind you of
anything on your bucket list
there's so many things i would like to
do
i would really like to for instance this
isn't a discreet item on a bucket list
but get back into scuba diving
like so yeah scuba diving is one of my
great loves i haven't done it in so long
and it is
really truly
if you get to the point where you're
reasonably comfortable and you can do
wall dives and really kind of hover
using your buoyancy what's a wall dive
uh or like a cliff dive so you where you
let's say you're swimming over coral
that's
i'm just making this up 30 feet below
the surface colors are still really
vibrant at that depth
and then there's just a cliff
and you drop off of this cliff and you
just go down this wall so you're looking
at
let's just call it a coral reef but it's
vertical instead of horizontal and you
look down and it's just into the abyss
and so you swim along a wall and you can
drop down go up and down looking at
everything there is to see and
i often use scuba diving and it doesn't
work for everyone of course but as a
metaphor for
psychedelic experiences
because
in the beginning like the first time you
dive the first
one two or three times you dive you're
just getting used to the equipment
you don't know necessarily reflexively
how to grab your like octopus or if you
lose your respirator how to deal with
that
you're constantly checking your gauge
you're screwing with your bcd i think
it's we see the buoyancy control device
yeah bcd where you're over inflating
your vest and letting the air out so you
really don't have much control and
you're
discombobulated but you you might only
notice a really large fish or a turtle
or a shark
or
seeing your peripheral vision
a school of fish but you're you're
really not seeing very much
and then as you get more comfortable
you see more and more you notice more
and more
and then you get to a point where
let's just say on a wall dive it doesn't
have to be a wall dive but where you can
control your buoyancy you're just less
at risk of smashing stuff with your feet
obviously because you're looking down
and it might be hundreds or thousands of
feet
and you can just hover and look at like
a square meter right like three by three
and it is an entire universe of life and
activity and you could spend an hour
just looking at that tiny patch
that wonder
this is something i thought about
this morning i was like
i think it's really hard to go wrong
if you
chase
chase might be too strong a word but
like pursue
wonder and awe
you can probably overdo it and dull your
senses and your appreciation of that
but
i think there's a wonder deficiency
in
most lives
not that you should have it three times
a week what's the line about a universe
and a grain of sand or something yeah
and so i think part of that is what is
there to wonder that's all around us all
the time yeah in your backyard on a tree
and like yeah it's one of those things
that we sometimes get reminded of yeah
and i always it always feels like the
most obvious trait thing
but also the most profound and
meaningful and the the scuba diving for
me
reinvigorates
my
powers of
fixed attention
like my attention to detail so when i
and i haven't gone scuba diving in quite
a long time but
when you're underwater and you're really
noticing all the details if you
try to maintain that as you come out of
the water you still notice more there's
a transfer i just love that floating so
for me the buoyancy i actually got
certified with another one of your
guests adam bazzali oh really and um
adam that point one if you breathe in
your neuroscience six-pack phd yeah you
disgusted
i know beautiful beautiful beautiful
fellow
i'm just jealous of one p bar workout
and uh incredible you know really
engaged dad too it's been so fun to see
how much he's gotten out of that and
given obviously but it's
anyway not to interrupt so you got
certified with adam yeah when you
breathe in and you float up a little bit
and you breathe out and you go down a
little bit when you can kind of control
your buoyancy with like the air in your
lilings
that's so meditative yeah and i've
actually like gone to that space
sometimes while meditating or sometimes
in dreams i really really appreciate it
but it also reminds me like i wish we
had like elon musk of the ocean
like some like crazy awesome billionaire
who was like exploring the ocean as much
as bezos and musk are going to space
yeah you know who's
i mean the first name that comes to mind
controversial guy but
he's really good at getting [ __ ] done
it's james cameron i was gonna say but
that's that's all we got that's that's
what we need two billionaires fighting
yeah
and then that will uh we'll finally map
the oceans and understand things yeah i
wonder who else is out there there's
gotta be somebody else out there well
we'll do we'll do some recon and put in
the show notes hopefully one of your
listeners can two of your listeners can
start competing for conquering the ocean
i know there are a few of you
billionaires out there listening to this
right now so please take a look at our
oceans
i would like to spend more time with
especially after doing work with the
amazon conservation team
which you've also contributed to
co-founded by
mark plotkin famous ethnobotanist
one of the proteges of richard evan
schulte's
out of harvard
i would like to spend some more time
because i have spent some but i would
like to spend much more time with some
of the
indigenous groups
in this case in south america it
wouldn't have to be in south america but
because i have access
before those ways
die out and i think it's
somewhat and again this is maybe where
you and i different but i think it's
kind of inevitable like i do think the
march of so-called progress and the
introduction of western goods and
consumerism and so on you know once you
have
sat phones and wi-fi and big-screen tvs
and so on there's a tremendous amount of
erosion
that takes place and i'm not
implying or saying that i
idolize
the old ways i mean
there's a lot of writing around the you
know it's like the so-called noble
savage like oh if we could all just
revert to like living in communities of
50 with the bare essentials like
everything would be wonderful and i
don't agree with that i don't think
that's true but
there is a lot of
medical knowledge and also
knowledge of how to treat
the whole person instead of just
suppress symptoms
especially not not despite but
especially including what we would
consider
placebo effect it's like harnessing the
power of ritual and myth
the power of the mind and narrative
exactly to basically
co-opt the power of the patient to help
them heal themselves
is
dramatically underexplored by western
scientists in those communities not to
say that would be my job because i'm not
a western scientist i'm not a scientist
but certainly on my bucket list would be
spending time with with some of those
groups because i do think
and this gets into some pretty strange
territory but there are other ways of
knowing
tell me more
well
if you're gonna give me a hard time i'm
gonna turn it around yeah yeah i'm not
gonna let you get away with it yeah yeah
there are i do think there are other
ways of knowing outside of things that
are easy to
put into a
cube of a laboratory and test with
you know placebo-controlled randomized
trials and it's i think it's
easy to become
dogmatic with
scientism
with like a capital s
in the same way that it is easy to
become dogmatic with
religion
without
truly having even a basic literacy or
understanding of
what we're talking about when one
discusses science which is a scientific
method a structured way of testing a
hypothesis that's all it is it's a
journey not a endpoint yeah exactly so
so for instance i mean the scientific
method itself is not good at generating
hypotheses it's good testing hypotheses
and it's a framework for doing our best
not to fool ourselves in a sense
but there are then observable phenomena
i'm just fingering this pile of ginger
chews here i might i might have a ginger
shoe this is gonna it's gonna be
terrible for audio so don't take this as
an indication of uh podcasting
professionalism but i am gonna have a
ginger chew because i love ginger
um i'll have this after i ask my next
question instead of while i'm talking
but there is a book i think it is
actually called another way of knowing
that
just discusses it's a discussion it's
basically an anthropological
exploration of a handful of
tribes i believe in malaysia so
certainly not in south america in this
instance
and
[Music]
phenomena that were
repeatedly observed
that seemed to
be very odd for instance
when this particular anthropologist
would head towards this village to visit
and he would be going by boat and
then trail and so on and so forth that
there would always be
someone waiting
at a trailhead to meet him
as if they were expecting him
but they had no prior notification that
he was on his way
so
what's happening here right is it
repeated coincidence sure it could be
right and like the
self-about hyper rationalists would be
like well come on now right and then and
uh
that would be the default but
i think it's
perhaps helpful to ask like what might
other possibilities be right like let's
generate a bunch of different hypotheses
before we edit like what are a bunch of
other
i don't even say plausible they could be
outrageous but like what are some other
hypotheses theories for how this might
happen
and
in these tight-knit
groups let's just call them tribes for
simplicity
you see a lot of these behaviors that
mimic some phenomena you see in the
natural
world with other species so if you read
say of wolves and men by barry lopez he
talks about wolves
being tracked like by scientists that
head off in a specific direction
traveling in a straight line
and
they intersect with a herd of caribou
that started like
300 miles away
and they perfectly intersect at a given
point where they're known to hunt and
it's like okay
that's cool what's happening
like
is it coincidence
maybe sure you can't rule that out it
could be
and you know i think about
as i say this i have some trepidation in
saying it because there are people
listening who'll be like oh my god
that's so ridiculous or they might even
say that's so unscientific
and what they mean by that is i can't
provide
definitive proof or some like
framework that provides perfect
explanatory power
but as i was thinking about this morning
if
you have say an eclipse
that's just thinking about thousands of
years
before this morning
eclipses were still happening right
humanoids have been around for a long
time right if the crossing of the bering
strait supposedly was whatever it was 20
30 40 000 years ago i don't really know
you know humanoids
even just in north and south americans
have been around for a long time and
prior to that even longer
so they've been looking up and seeing
these things
how would they have explained them
thousands and thousands of years ago
certainly not the way that we explain
them today nonetheless the eclipses were
happening and it was kind of cool we saw
a little presentation from one of the
people here on different cultures and
you know i think in china it was a
dragon eating the sun
and vietnam was a frog there was like
different sort of
myths and and
like every culture had a version of it
yeah it's pretty cool and i'll give
another example uh during but how's that
connected to no i'm gonna connect it so
so what i mean is
i think you can observe and record
phenomena
and even in the absence of perfect
explanatory power some
theory that holds up to
modern
scrutiny
just the fact that someone can't explain
how something works doesn't mean it
doesn't exist that's what i'm trying to
say so for instance while we were in
lockdown during covid there was this
video that went kind of viral of a
coyote and a badger
going out on a on a hunt together
and like the coyote would like trail out
in front because it wasn't trailing was
leading in front and like stop and like
wag its tail and look like a dog playing
with another dog and then pull the
badger along and that
from a naturalist or field by a
biological perspective at least
according some people shouldn't happen
right like that that was always a myth
and in some of the the native northern
native american
traditions they talked about that coyote
and badger hunting together as talked
about right but it was considered a myth
and then boom now you have some video
footage and it's like ah
look at that
okay so i do think that just because
cultures have superstitions and beliefs
that are not founded on hard evidence
and let's not fool ourselves we we still
have a lot of that even the most
technologically advanced among us have
plenty of those it's somehow a
phenomenon can't exist
right if you don't have perfect
explanatory power this is kind of
ridiculous like if you study the history
of scientific discovery
you observe a lot of things far before
you can radio waves germs yeah radio
waves
like so many invisible things happening
all around us all the time yeah we look
back like 20 years from whatever point
in time
or let's say 50 years just to make it a
little easier
50 years before whatever point in time
the discussion is taking place is like
the dark ages right like oh my god i
can't believe we didn't know this oh my
god look how ridiculous that is in
hindsight
instead of neglecting all the while the
fact that of course
if we were to be looking back at today
50 years from now
as some doctors say like half of what we
know is wrong we just don't know which
half yeah that's why i think it's so
important to make space for people to
update their views i think it's so silly
when we like get mad at someone
something i said 30 years ago it's like
yeah you're waffling
no like when i get new information i
change my mind what do you do yeah and
that'll be i'm sure this thing's on your
early podcast maybe our last podcast i
no longer agree with that one of us said
and that's beautiful like in programming
we talk about like if you're not
embarrassed by your old code you're not
learning
you should feel bad when you look at
your code if you think it's better than
you can do now or great that means you
haven't grown as a developer so i think
it's really important to always be
evolving in that way
but what you brought up does make me
think about how much communication is
happening
all around us all the time yeah that we
don't understand yeah whether that's
bird calls or what we heard with the
penguins how they're able to connect
with each other and identify each other
i just saw the documentary fantastic fun
guy yeah yeah great damn it's yeah super
fun yeah louis schwartzberg yeah and the
the mycelium networks like there's so
much
communication that's happening all
around us
and that's another thing that i think is
so interesting to explore yeah are we
ever gonna understand aliens if we can't
understand dogs although i heard there's
a startup around this that's trying to
do like machine learning around dog
barks oh god machine learning
machine is it machine learning or deep
learning yeah there are all these terms
you slap it on without the ai you can
raise more money yeah yeah although you
know hey if someone can help me i'll
send my second listener then we'll do it
we'll do another question better
communicate with molly i'm into it so
what else will be on my bucket list i
want you know it's such a simple thing i
want to get another dog oh
yeah to to accompany molly
and also to
have some overlap so that i
i think if molly passes away it'll be
very hard for me to get another dog
would you clone molly no
you want to share it anything about
cloning
i might know something about
chloe you you can clone cats dogs and
horses now
in america well let's let's get more
specific
i think the company is called viagen
and uh
and yeah you can pay and they will take
a skin sample
from the living animal
and uh they make an embryo from it and
embed it in a surrogate
and do you know anything about this
no comment
no comment all right well i'll let the
audience draw from that what they may uh
i would not clone molly i think the
uncanny valley
i i don't think i would do that
for myself
no i wouldn't try to do like mali 2.0 i
think i'd feel very
ethically conflicted about that it's
like emotionally conflicted too so i
don't think i would do that
but i would get
a like mini me to play with molly who
then
carries on the torch i would definitely
do that yeah
it was that
i
was party to this but the person who who
wanted to do the cloning i was very very
surprised
you were surprised i was incredibly
surprised uh that this person wanted to
do it
why were you surprised religious
backgrounds
she's catholic are catholics against
cloning you know
i don't know for sure but it seems like
it should be on that list
i don't know um i guess if it's skin
it's okay huh
yeah
and um i was surprised but it's been i i
now have met this clone
uh the first of the cones like a
congressional hearing i love your
wording
and uh
i've met said clone
sound mr sander a beautiful thing about
it is that the previous dog whose past
had had some was a rescue and had like a
difficult early life and so even though
i knew this dog for you know 15 years
she would always be pretty skittish with
me or any man in the room which is just
so heartbreaking to think like what
happened to her when she was younger and
this new dog
with the same genetic material the
genetic twin
is so excited to see me
it's like a six sigma excitement event
when i when i return
uh when i walk through the door and it's
kind of amazing so
yeah
but but completely different so i would
say that
it's not it's just like a twin a genetic
twin coloring will be different
personalities totally different i think
really shows you nature versus nurture
as well
oh that's for sure which i think for
dogs can be huge although you know way
more about dogs and i spent so much time
training molly
and another reason i would like to have
another dog is that she'll help train
the other dog hmm yeah they'll pass on
good and bad behavior right yeah she
doesn't have too many bad behavior she
has a few
but not too many and
for people who want to look at
the communication side you can google i
think there's a radio lab episode on the
the wood wide web as they call it
which talks about inter i think it's
enter i always mix up enter an intro but
inter-tree communication oh yeah
and trees will privilege ones that are
closely related to progeny yeah yeah and
as they're gonna die they'll basically
like drop their resources into the root
system and distribute to direct
descendants pretty cool it's so wild
and the
reciprocal relationship with
the
fungal networks is just just incredible
so you can look at that let's not forget
also it wasn't that long ago
i don't know the exact dates but i think
it's within the last hundred years
that doctors or surgeons would operate
on infants without anesthesia
wow it's not that long ago i might be
getting it slightly off but
our assumptions about consciousness
and communication
and perception have been so consistently
off that i think it's fair to assume
that we're still pretty off a lot to
learn yeah i think my second buck i mean
honestly this trip has been a bucket
list
the emperor penguins hope we were going
to hopefully see the totality over them
but it was too cloudy so that's why we
came to this union glacier camp seeing
the totality and so i'll put a travel
thing as the second one which is i'd
love to go to egypt with my sister
why egypt she wants to go
and i
think it'd be pretty incredible so
here's a bucket list for me is taking a
bunch of my closest friends to japan
that's a huge snow cap
in the background
is it showing up on the levels it showed
up on the level so that it would be the
the tucker 5 which the staff used to
refer to because it was the largest
tucker snow cap that had ever been
custom built
and they would refer to it as the on
radio they refer to it as the mother
tucker but then that got
that was not pc apparently so it got
vetoed at some point now it's the tucker
five how boring
i prefer the mother tucker
that might be part of this podcast
episode title as well
uh which is funny because you always
make fun of me for not cursing i do i do
yeah matt does not curse why don't you
curse
don't give me that i have so many
advices i needed to get rid of one
nonsense
you always use that
you know we don't have the internet so i
can't confirm but i think the english
language has more words than any other
language
has a lot of words and i just love
finding that really great word
to match things
except for curse words except for curse
words why not
is that a religious thing i actually i
had a um
one of the first wordpress blogs
actually was a private
blog myself and four friends had
out of high school and i was looking
back at entry from like 99 or something
and it had a curse word in it from you
from me ooh what first i don't remember
which one oh it's just nor could i say
it or [ __ ]
but i was so shocked because so i just
hope i would get you there i think i've
forgotten when i stopped but i think it
was influenced by reading someone or
something around um
just expressedness of the english
language
finding the right word for things and
other ways so i i don't exclaim much you
don't have a very ejaculatory style
to your speaking yeah what do you mean
you don't exclaim much what does that
even mean um gosh darn it or you know
that's fighting words
yeah i don't
yeah don't explain much we have someone
else on the trip who exclaims a lot not
me
like an exclamation would be like if i
stub my toe
or something like i'm not gonna so what
do you say when you stub your toe you
just bite your just grin like bite your
tongue and i probably just make a noise
like a yelp
so if someone like cuts you off in
traffic i guess i mean you may be so
sound that you just don't get annoyed
but if you get annoyed do you say
anything
i like to tell myself that they
are doing something urgent
or have something in their life that
like
you know they they really need to get
that spot when does when does mac get
upset what are some matte triggers
besides people spelling wordpress with
lyric is p you know where i'm nods and
at all i get upset on behalf of others
oh yeah i've seen this you've seen it
yeah yeah and so i'm more likely
to be probably to like a fault like
overly protective sometimes a person
themselves might not be mad but i'll
like get mad on their behalf injustice
yeah really bugs mean
so what's your response then so most
people are like god [ __ ] damn it they
most people would curse to let some
steam out what do you do oh good even
[Music]
this soft spoken
weapon of
incredible
menace you got to be careful with the
mullen wag or the
is one of the staff here for domes when
we did our
drone test earlier would you it's better
than mullet wig which i used to get in
school
you're welcome
or adam gazzolly calls you molly legs
molly legs yeah it's another good one
sometimes i get mullen webb which i
actually kind of like that's good get
some web in there mullen webb i like
that
okay we'll come back to the get even
part another time
uh
let's see this is just the one that i
pulled out say we do maybe one more
because my bladder's about to explode
but my [ __ ] bee bottle is full that's
like nowhere to put it
well i guess i can try to pee into the
scotch whiskey bottle that we've now
sorry glenn mirandi i know my god that's
like the worst yank pronunciation of
that ever
but if i have to pee in your bottle i
apologize in advance uh do intentions
matter more or less than actions hmm
yeah what's the um legal word for this
means rey or something oh i don't know
yes i think they do
intentions matter more
all right
tell me more about mullenweb
do intentions matter more what i like
about intentions is the intentionality
it's a choosing it's the
deliberateness of a decision
to do something and i think that's
super important
for us to do
maybe that sound a little abstract what
you choose to do yeah
i think is more important than what
necessarily happens along the way which
you have less control over you have
complete control over your choice so i'm
going to say intentions matter more than
actions
but i'm defining actions in a certain
way how are you defining actions things
that happen
what the [ __ ] are we talking about
okay actions are things that happen
yeah so for example
you intend
to give me a present
but your action on the way is you
stumble and
on my step on my foot
okay and your intention to me matters
more than the fact you stepped on my
foot and broke a toe so let's say
there's uh
someone who decides i want to give back
and do the right thing but they have no
money no resources no network no
leverage and then there's so they have
this pure intention but they don't end
up being effective
in
impact let's just say and i know that's
kind of a broad statement then there's
some person who just
cold-blooded capitalist killer like
takes no prisoners racks up incredible
wealth
and then says i'm going to give to a
bunch of charities because that's the
right social move
i'm getting all these boards create
really good optics
have a conversation
at these dinner parties blah blah blah
blah blah so it's not coming from
virtuous intention per se but
has an outsized impact just because of
the sheer resources behind it i'll take
it
you take you'll take it you'll take the
second one i think doing the right thing
for the wrong reason is still the right
thing which i guess takes us more to
actions and attention yeah
what's your answer to that one
i think actions come more yeah so it's
the right thing for the wrong reason
would still be the right thing and that
matters more yeah yeah for me which
isn't to say i would like people to do
the right thing for the wrong reason
but
you know i was chatting with uh i can't
remember who it was i was chatting with
but they were saying might have been
when i got i got a tour of
bethlehem
from an arab christian which is
definitely a minority
and
i don't know if it was him it might have
been someone else who was saying you
know jews and
and muslims should really get along on
some level because they care more about
actions than they do what's
in your heart what you believe whereas
christians care about like what you
believe like you can do all these
atrocious things but then
truly believe and repent and
be saved
and
i thought about how much
all of that has likely shaped
cultures and empires and civilizations
right just that
different lens on things if it's like we
don't care what you believe it's all
about what you do like follow these
rituals do these things don't eat this
thing on this date
abcde
versus like the belief slash maybe
intention is what matters
even if you [ __ ] up and make these
terrible mistakes that's okay
of course i'm gonna offend like pretty
much everybody on the planet by what i
just said
but i
but
i do think this question though that i
threw out from
this deck of cards is an interesting one
right intention versus action i'm glad
that we disagreed on it too we find the
points where we disagree to be
interesting things to mine all right
last question because my bladder is
about to explode and the uh the neck of
this uh scotch whiskey bottles way too
narrow
for any attempt at reasonable accuracy
it's not tim is sharing again yeah no
it's not it's not a claim to any like
you know coke can like girth who are we
kidding we're in antarctica but
in any case
somebody with us was like let's take
let's all take a naked shot together and
we're like no
no
no not the most flattering shot we could
do right now what are you grateful for
right now
hmm
give you an easy answer
and a harder answer i mean i'm so
grateful for the time we spent together
yeah for that too me too
the bigger and hard answer i would say
is i'm so
astounded at um
the creation and rollout of the vaccines
and like it gives me hope for maybe
humanity solving other big problems if
we can
all kind of focus on the same thing at
the same time
and uh yeah so everyone who worked on
covet really grateful for
i'm also really grateful
for the time that we've been able to
spend on this trip it's been a while
since we've done one of these
and
we've been disconnected which has been
yeah twitchy for me i tried to download
and scroll half the internet before we
went offline through wikipedia
let me just read about u.s postal
service let me read this andre
i am grateful for this trip it's been a
great trip i've had a lot of people ask
me why i came to antarctica like why am
i interested in antarctica and i am
interested in antarctica but the main
reason was just to spend time
with you we've had so many great trips
before
and included and now this one adding it
to the list
so super grateful for that
super grateful for my girlfriend
honestly she's uh
incredible puts up with a lot of
nonsense
i don't think i'm the hardest person to
be with but i certainly don't think i'm
the easiest person
and
she's just
she's just been such a wonderful
compliment and i think we are so
different yet our values are so similar
that it allows us to really stretch
in ways that
it's a good thing to look for in a
partner i would say is like where you
are different in many ways but then
exactly the same on a few key
values goals
fighting style communication yes she is
the cleanest fighter i would say the
cleanest fighter i've ever been with
probably good influence on you too i
would say that yeah i would say so you
know hopefully she would say the same
about me i think so
and so i'm very very grateful for that
and i'm grateful for having the bladder
capacity of a camel
[Laughter]
so i don't even know what time it is god
what time is it it's probably like 10 or
11 or god knows goodness it is now yeah
almost 11. so probably a good time for
the campaign it is 11 p.m and it is
bright as high noon
as we speak hey also thank you you know
we both shared a lot of personal stuff
on this one yeah we did
thanks for that vulnerability yeah thank
you too man yeah really great to do this
and let's not wait another five years
all right
all right man love you bud
and uh to everybody
who is listening you can find links to
anything we've talked about books and so
on i don't know what else
we'll find a bunch of random links and
put them in the show notes for you to
peruse at tim dot blog thanks for that
also recommendation from mr mullenweb
team.blog
podcast and until next time
just ever so slightly kinder than you
think necessary and that includes to
yourself
and thanks for tuning in
hey guys this is tim again just one more
thing before you take off and that is
five bullet friday would you enjoy
getting a short email from me every
friday that provides a little fun before
the weekend between one and a half and
two million people subscribe to my free
newsletter my super short newsletter
called five bullet friday easy to sign
up easy to cancel it is basically a half
page that i send out every friday to
share the coolest things i've found or
discovered or have started exploring
over that week it's kind of like my
diary of cool things it often includes
articles i'm reading books i'm reading
albums perhaps gadgets gizmos all sorts
of tech tricks and so on that gets sent
to me by my friends including a lot of
podcast guests and these strange
esoteric things end up in my field and
then i test them and then i share them
with you so if that sounds fun again
it's very short a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend something to think about
if you'd like to try it out just go to
tim.blog friday type that into your
browser tim dot blog slash friday drop
in your email and you'll get the very
next one
thanks for listening
this episode is brought to you by tonal
imagine having an entire gym's worth of
equipment in a device smaller than a
flat screen tv something that could fit
potentially even in a closet
fits in my closet by eliminating
traditional weights tonal can deliver
200 pounds of resistance with a sleek
design that can fit nearly anywhere it's
like having an entire gym and personal
trainer right in your home tonal's
patented digital weight system senses
your strength and adjusts the weight
automatically in real time so you can
get the most out of every workout a
number of friends including competitive
athletes who have doubled their strength
in short order in a lot of exercises and
part of the reason that's possible is it
uses a revolutionary system of dynamic
resistance powered by electric motors
for strength you can feel you can also
do things like eccentrics
over time tonal learns from your body
and automatically increases the weight
exactly when you can handle it tonal
also uses 17 sensors to provide
real-time feedback on your form and
technique allowing you to get the most
effective workout every time it's a
strength training machine with
adjustable arms that provides more than
170 exercises for a full body workout
and that can include squats deadlifts
bench presses overhead pulls bicep curls
and more so check it out try tonal the
smartest home gym for 30 days in your
home tonal is so confident that you'll
love it they offer a full money back
guarantee you can now get tonal from 63
dollars per month at zero percent
interest over 48 months
visit
www.tonal that's tonal.com
and for a limited time get 100 off when
you use promo code tim 100 at checkout
that's www.tonal.com
promo code
tim 100 tim100
tonal be your strongest
this episode is brought to you by eight
sleep my god am i in love with eight
sleep good sleep is the ultimate game
changer more than 30 percent of
americans struggle with sleep and i'm a
member of that sad group temperature is
one of the main causes of poor sleep and
heat has always been my nemesis i've
suffered for decades tossing and turning
throwing blankets off putting them back
on and repeating ad nozzle but now
i am falling asleep in record time
faster than ever why because i'm using a
simple device called the pod pro cover
by eight sleep it's the easiest and
fastest way to sleep at the perfect
temperature it pairs dynamic cooling and
heating with biometric tracking to offer
the most advanced but most user-friendly
solution on the market i polled all of
you guys on social media about the best
tools for sleep enhancing sleep and
eight sleep was by far and away the
crowd favorite i mean people were just
raving fans of this so i used it and
here we are add the pod pro cover to
your current mattress and start sleeping
as cool as 55 degrees fahrenheit or as
hot as 110 degrees fahrenheit it also
splits your bed in half so your partner
can choose a totally different
temperature my girlfriend runs hot all
the time she doesn't need cooling she
loves the heat and we can have our own
bespoke temperatures on either side
which is exactly what we're doing now
for me and for many people the result
eight sleep users fall asleep up to 32
percent faster reduce sleep
interruptions by up to 40 and get more
restful sleep overall i can personally
attest to this because i track it in all
sorts of ways it's the total solution
for enhanced recovery so you can take on
the next day feeling refreshed and now
my dear listeners that's you guys you
can get 250 off of the pod pro cover
that's a lot simply go to eight sleep
dot com slash tim or use code tim that's
eight all spelled out e-i-g-h-t
sleep dot com slash tim or use coupon
code tim tim eight sleep dot com slash
tim for 250 off your pod pro cover
[Applause]
you